how important is screenplay structure to
your overall writing I mean is there a
specific structure you try to follow I
try to I found because I I kind of
learned how to write through reading a
ton of scripts like at new lane when I
was there I just read all scripts all
the time so I find that most of my stuff
does kind of fall into the you know
traditional like three act structure
save the cat thing or that's the
inciting incident I don't get into
there's some stuff and I shouldn't roll
my eyes at it because people do but you
know there's some books that are like
well you have to have they have like
they've broken it down to like super
micro science and for me it's just like
too much like you know in a way you
don't to beat the creativity out of
somebody by giving you too much of a
structure you know I think that's why I
think the three-act structure is enough
for yes you know at the end of your
second act something's got to like
propel you into the third act and you
know things have got to get you know
more intense and more intense to your
finale but you know I think a lot of
times even like I have a lot of friends
I go to film school and their one thing
is like they're like I wish I didn't
spend that money to make a film because
they just they're like we would have
learned a lot more and it's not you know
anything against going to film school
but it's just again if you're trying to
teach somebody somebody whose artistic
how to you can teach them how to channel
that into a format that's gonna be more
palpable to the masses but if you start
getting too much into like you you know
page 20 this has to happen on page 30
this has to happen then you're like
stifling people's creativity in a way
but there is a reason if there is a
structure like that sometimes because I
had friends give me a script and like
the first drafts like 140 pages I'm like
I'm not right this is not a script it's
like a miniseries like they're like oh
but if you understand it's like if they
can tell the Titanic and 120 pages I'm
sure you can tell your story about a
woman who's trying to find true love in
her small town in less than 140 pages so
you know there there there is a wisdom
to the basic structure but all when I
sit down to write something usually I
start with a concept
I'm very concept driven just because I
think that's working at a studio for so
long I know that the concept is what's
going to get people's attention or not
get it so I start with using a concept
and then I think of some scares as well
and then start you know with building a
story around the concept is how I
approach you but I know a lot of people
start from like characters and some
people start from a story so it's
everybody's got their own personal kind
of creative style and how they on how
they work but for me I always I always
start with the concept of the story and
I try to think at least of a concept
that's kind of high concept that you can
kind of if you tell somebody in a minute
and they're and I call that sounds cool
you know so that's that's kind of where
I start off when I'm writing
you